literally
good-morning Millennials way I saw her
and P like fighting yesterday that's
really cute and I'm literally dead no
I'm dying
how Q it like another way like I really
don't want to like being Wang but like
you really need to start like being on
time for stuff cuz like we all have jobs
and like stuff and like I know you're
super busy like with the kids but like
when they're at school like you need to
be on time no I I know that work is your
priority but it's just not mine like
that's just not who I am and so my kids
are my priority and I'm gonna give them
a vegan organic lunch even if it means
being late no but like we understand
that but like the business listen
Kourtney listen to your sister
mom thank you mom like seriously you
ruined my life
you wrecked you know that my perfectly
my perfect life
you be a good mother to you you gave me
a perfect life and it ruined me what
like how could you say that like you're
seriously seriously like we're all here
like working together and I know that
like that is not important to you but
like it's important to us and like the
kids are in school like what are you
doing like you're just going on vacation
every six months you have different
priorities than me and I I respect that
that's what you want to do with your
time and with your life but that's just
not how I want to live my life like my
therapist said that you're a [ __ ]
lunatic my therapist you're a lunatic
and your [ __ ] therapist is a [ __ ]
lunatic my therapist said get the [ __ ]
out Kim calm down my life I was a
perfectly good therapist like who is she
what does she know you can go run your
business that I'm gonna [ __ ] all over
and still use your phone case no like
seriously like just keep editing your
photos like please end scene for now
wowie in and out of
after I am sweating like a [ __ ] it I'm
sweating like Kim Kardashian in church I
was just like to note a few things about
today please note the cherry tomato on
Margo's martini
oh sorry Krista's Marty a snitch as
Chris aka Joan Jett is the greatest
thing I've ever seen Margo what's really
in there water okay that's good yeah
what do you guys drinking um I'm like
the wig is making me sweat so much I
don't know how someone walks around with
hair like this like I think my hair is
long like normally and it is but this is
next level like the readiness is it's
pertinent today's wind gets blown Jackie
today's eyebrows season for you like
people always yell at you want to
Instagram like to draw on your eyebrows
and like honestly I couldn't disagree
with them more Here I am what do you
guys think I really now I really can't
move my far head so I'm totally in
character yeah that me hair length is
good on you it's good wigs are helpful
to try out different hair lines for sure
but you really can't get a good gauge
like because it has like so much side
value yeah really feeling well I think
that the the outfit is really working
for you and I would suggest it like at
another time in real life you know
perhaps like it looks it looks better in
person than it looks on the show I would
say yeah I would say that as well and
honestly like I woke up this morning I
was like I have nothing to be asking
because I was going to like the sweat
pant boot look but then I realized like
just stay true to myself you know yeah
and I'm honestly there more on outfits I
try on like more kind of understand Kim
and her aesthetic ya know it's
flattering like it's a lot really good
thank you I think so too
[Music]
spooky year
[Applause]
we have a very spooky show for you as
always know it's tough cuz like last
year we truly outdid ourselves and it
was such a last-minute like throw away
like let's just and if you ever watched
our episode I highly suggest it so we
were you know we were torn about what to
do this year but they say you know if
you do what you love you'll never work a
day in your life right this is what we
look for they say if you're Kourtney
Kardashian you'll never work a day in
your life right because your sisters
carry the load for your entire family
right and all you have to do is show up
to film and sit on your couch and drink
oh speaking of you know I don't have
time to you know grab a meal today so I
know we're filming in stuff but I'm just
like a little yeah get you a girl that
can do both
like literally north to the cutest thing
like I'll show you a video um once I
mean gets here she's literally so cute
no I know and P is like a tomboy why
would you say that I mean she is like
you should see her like the way she
looks at North like with all of North's
like makeup and stuff it's so Q it well
I mean it's my kids have their
priorities in order and like I get that
like North Mike loves makeup right Andy
she wants me and she's excited she shows
out the other night her restaurant wild
animal what do you mean she's eating
everything in sight but North my little
more you know but my kids are organic so
Kanye did the cliche time today Connie
did the craziest thing what like we were
just like babe like I need a band-aid
and I was like get your own band-aid
Kanye and he was like literally like so
mad like babe get your own band-aid
that's really crazy but maybe he's just
feeling like with all the kids like just
he needs a little attention a lesson I
could have learned when I still had
Scott around mm yeah speaking of Scott
did you see his Instagram I did but I
don't follow it so I didn't see it what
does like unis think of like the whole
thing
I mean Eunice is just he's at Delilah
right now beating up a nightclub
security guard so he has his hands full
by the way thanks for that Chris I
appreciate the timing oh you're welcome
thanks mom devil works hard but I work
harder by the way like I don't like what
you get grossed out or anything but like
like given quite a bit together for like
a long time so think you're gonna get
married I mean I don't know I'm a little
old for that doesn't really like I'm not
like I'm having kids well as long as
you're realistic here
are the best five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast or
morning salad it is so hard talking so
slow like then like um it's impossible
how I want to think that the podcast is
on delay know for sure but like how do
they even have conversations like all we
do is jump in and interrupt each other I
know and we were still interrupting each
other that's Kim and Kourtney like
whatever they also like have nothing to
say so maybe that's why they don't
interrupt each other literally okay it's
also like not that hard to talk like
them like word wise cuz we also just say
let me say the same things but just
slower and there I mean I'm dead yeah
I'm laughing so hard you know I'm crying
it was the funniest thing ever I can't
stop laughing I don't I can't breathe
someone stop me call an ambulance
by the way where's Chloe she's in Crete
she's in the clean um yeah I mean she's
another one priorities out of whack like
we used to be so close and I just feel
like these days she's just spending so
much time with you
but it's like when you when you become a
mother like like you said like your
priorities change and I feel like
Chloe's gonna be such a good mom
no she will she will and I'm like really
excited I feel like we're gonna have
like really similar parenting styles in
terms of our priorities drinking word by
the way priorities so I'm like so
excited for her and just like this M
amazing journey she's about to go on
like I I really couldn't be happier for
my sister no I'm happy for her too
no I mean like I'm like happiest for her
you know yeah but I'm really happy for
her know and like I get that for like
for sure but like I think I'm like the
happiest any person could be for Chloe
like our parenting styles are so similar
like that baby's gonna like change her
life and I just I can't wait for her to
experience like what I
experiencing like through the growth of
my family right which I experienced
first right like so long ago it's like
you probably don't remember no I
remember and I think I'm gonna have more
kids
yeah with Scott it should I write him an
email about it how dare you how dare you
no I just what I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] no I
really like was just trying to be like
considerate because I think that like
you would never admit it but like you
really want all your how dare you how
dare you write that just crying I don't
know what I don't think I was really
just you're such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
Courtney just coming your sister's
trying to help thank you mom
stop taking her side I'm not taking her
side but you're being irrational no I
mean it's like everyone knows that on
mom's favorite so like stop complaining
about actually Kylie's my favorite but
you were her why she makes more money
yeah 10% baby it's fine it's so hard not
to go back into calories it's so hard
not to like just want to applaud
snitcher I want to turn the performance
of a lifetime leave this [ __ ] channel
the whole time know is same Sinnott she
what Christy wouldn't deliver the past
five stories no okay I'll leave it up to
my girls I'll just take 10% I'll just
take 10% of the show by the way did you
guys see that Caitlyn thing I did in
Vanity Fair yeah how does like did you
just like don't really want to talk
about her okay
you're so mature yeah it must be so hard
for you but like unlike think about
Kendall like I know that this is really
hard for her because like she feels torn
between her parents and I think she
feels like you know like they're being
hypocritical but after what Caitlyn said
about mom and Vanity Fair like I don't
know how you can even take a side
there's literally only one side thank
you I mean and there's two sides to
every story and I just feel like if
you're gonna be inviting Scott to the
Christmas party then Caitlyn should be
invited to write but like it's the same
way how like are you gonna invite Eunice
and Scott to the Christmas party like um
you already invited Scott so the least
you could do is invite Kaitlyn but he's
family Kaitlyn's family you don't want
your kids to be together with their dad
I mean it's only in an awkward position
that I'll have to describe to my
therapist and like that puts me in an
awkward
to describe it you know when I get that
you feel like your priorities are being
put in an awkward position and I I feel
that like I understand but it's like
think it's like it's about the kids like
the memories like when I look back on
our childhood like it's so positive and
like I just love that we were like all
so close in age and we want that for our
kids and like you're trying to take
those memories away that's what I want
for my kids but I have to make those
memories because some people don't have
their priorities in order and I don't
want my kids I don't want that for them
like I don't want that life for them
where they just don't have their
priorities in order
I know but it's it's one day like and if
you like just fork to sake like yours
you're you're you go like your kids will
be so happy I'll think about it
I mean I have to schedule time to think
cuz I'm on the phone with my lawyer
working on a stick I'm working on six
different deals like pretty little
things that they would name a dress
after me if I post 16 times no I mean
that's great for you but I have to run
to my bread packaging meeting for Kiki
wbd like if I don't do this now we won't
get out by the holiday and I have to go
why can't you just take the meeting at
4:00 a.m. because people are asleep I
don't understand why you wouldn't just
take the meeting at 4:00 a.m. so that I
can pick my kids up from school like
that is just so because I had to
coordinate everyone schedules all the
Glitter early everyone in the family
we're really gonna have to comment
midnight and post by herself like can
you just let the babysitter the six baby
sitters pick up the kids today like
literally the fact that you wouldn't
just move your meeting to 4:00 a.m. so I
can give my kids dinner like it's just
what's wrong with this favor
[ __ ] lunatic get the [ __ ] out of here
you're a [ __ ] lunatic sorry we all
have brands and lives and businesses and
that's hard for you to understand get
the [ __ ] out you [ __ ] lunatic I think
everyone just needs to calm down okay
men shut the [ __ ] up okay shut up [ __ ]
off
stupid [ __ ] love you okay Kim likes an
absolute once no totally and she takes
out anyone in her way totally okay first
story back to
oh this first story like really shook me
I did some major Instagram stalking
Tyler Lautner confirms he's in a
relationship as he goes Instagram
official with his new girlfriend oh my
god I saw this this morning did you see
this and Jesus regular she's like a
basic [ __ ] she's nursing school like
she looks like I know her no totally I
was somehow she wasn't a toaster
she is Jesus in her bio like she's so
normal no she's so normal apparently
she's friends with his sister and
they've been dating for a while because
he's been commenting like
thirst-trapping-- things on her
Instagram for a few months now and I'm
like so you know it's real I'm so here
for it I feel like he really needs a
normal girl like um I'm from Taylor
Swift to Billie lourd her name is Taylor
yeah that's commends abs weird because
now it's like the third date in a girl
in a row that he dated with the same
person who else Taylor Swift at this
girl Taylor and I'm sure though I'm sure
he ended up like honestly I'm really
happy for him I've always been team
Jacob I've never been team J Cup and in
real life like I am team Taylor Lautner
yeah and it was like a good guy and they
don't think he's like there's monster
for the fame and he transitioned well
from being a child actor like he was
underrated Lee in so many things as like
an 11 year old boy he was in Sharkboy
and Lavagirl and he was actually cuter
as an 11 year old that i think he is now
and it's like the comments on her
pictures like her friends are freaking
out that she's dating Taylor Lautner and
like done is here for as well they
should know I'm into Taylor Lautner at
the VMAs last year and honestly like
this year it's hard I just trying to
lines are blurred because you're really
just so similar it's so true no I ran
into you know when Taylor longer I guess
he wasn't like one of those like like
series um from Harry Potter like maybe
like you know things don't work out with
Eunice like he's like 21 like you might
like him I don't know I just really
don't want to date someone that's like
in the scene or cool or nice or someone
who would like leave supportive comments
on my Instagram because I just feel like
that would go against like Who I am and
what your therapist is story and how I
want to live my life you know well yeah
I understand that I just thought like
you know you would want to know when
like a boy comes of age in Hollywood
cause I mean it's just really none of
your business
know for sure just lemme know when you
pick up the kids up from school okay
psychopaths leading by the night calling
someone a lunatic is now my thing it's
such a great like nobody uses that word
it's like a 90s word people are like
you're psycho but like a lunatic it's a
great word and I'm gonna start using it
it's a good word I don't know if it like
conveys all of the what I'm saying so I
feel like once you just call someone
crazy it's like you you don't have an
argument they're just like crazy lunatic
like falls under that umbrella yeah but
like Millennials have ruined the word
crazy a little bit you're like wow
that's crazy
no it's I mean it's literally so crazy
right mom yeah crazy what are you
working on today you know just Kylie is
a photo shoot later so I'm probably just
gonna go and help her and you're
definitely not going to anything club
meets birth beyond right well she's in
Cleveland so now I'm not gonna fly there
are you gonna get in any of the pictures
for Kylie shoes I mean if she wants me
to you see what you got me for my
birthday yeah yeah it was epic it was my
idea
must be nice it was my therapist's idea
to tell her to tell Kylie to get up
really well I'm so shocked that your
therapist had something that you're
welcome by the way
did you si what hold on sir what with
Angela Angela yeah I mean I just don't
like have the time and space for that
sort of negativity in my life and that's
just not however no no that's just not
how I want to live my life anymore like
I didn't I don't want this you know
right maybe it's just like maybe you
feel that way cuz like you're really
like just I don't know like not that
interesting like to look at I mean it's
right it's really [ __ ] rude for you to
say do you know what people on the
internet say about you versus me no I
don't read things on the internet cuz I
have a [ __ ] business well then I had
brands package and things to do okay
next story her to bed the way I just I
want a heart for one more second on the
Taylor a lot everything I think it's
incredibly cute and it never happens and
you always know that seems like he's
dating a fan it's you always know that
someone's a real like oh they got an
actual down-to-earth person and they
haven't like become a thirst monster
Hollywood person when they date someone
normal for the real world and the
perfect example is Mark Wahlberg is
married so I can absolutely nobody yeah
and they have a lovely family and a
lovely life together and I don't know if
they're applying
I don't want to hear about him about
Mark Wahlberg yeah yeah
perhaps wife actually know what that's
gonna I'm gonna switch skiers into a
different story because it goes back to
a story I reported last week now I need
to talk so quickly I need to get it all
out like because it's been 20 minutes
and nothing because we reported a story
last week about Jen garner and her new
man and we have a story today Jen Jenna
Dewan new boyfriend is Tony winners
Steve Kazee so I want your your thoughts
on both okay but the Jennifer Gardner
thing to read the lines that they've
been dating for a while
this whole thing has been like a roll
out she didn't like obviously her and
Ben Affleck haven't been together for a
very long time right and the timing for
her make said she's America's Sweetheart
right like she can't like be engaged in
a month so right we'll probably hear
about the engagement in six months
probably they're doing like a rebrand
rollout which you know what I love her
plenty of brands do but anyways Channing
Tatum isn't the only one moving on in
his personal life amid reports that
Tatum is leading singer Jessie J it's
been revealed that his estranged wife
Jenna Dewan is dating Tony award-winner
Steve Kazee do on went to Ally's famed
haunted hayride in Griffith Park this
week with a group of friends including
kizhi the two have reportedly been
spending time together since being
spotted at george clooney and randy
Gerber's Halloween bash where they were
spotted kissing the blast reported okay
so she's seeing a Tony like a Tony guy
which is actually like pretty low-key
look at Aaron Chris kind of vibe yeah
what do you think I don't know there's
so few Tony winners who aren't gay he
that like good for her oh that's so true
um I don't know I don't really get Jenna
to Juan's level of Fame like I don't
understand it whatsoever
no same like she was in one literally
one movie a franchise that maybe I had
two movies and like she became famous
for being someone's wife and like now
we're supposed to care like about her I
don't sorry
I know but anything people I care about
her haircuts I know that's way harsh ty
yeah well I don't know she is also like
another one that just seems like so fake
to me like this is also planned
yes she's like going on a hill I try to
be a [ __ ] yeah or she's just like so
like calculating like you don't go from
being just like a backup dancer to being
in page six like right by chance right
well like try let's think of like what
angles she could be playing dating a
Tony winner she is a dancer maybe she
wants me amber goes to Broadway mm-hmm
maybe maybe or maybe she just like wants
to be seen with someone but I feel like
if her next person like you would think
she
rise her star with right that's what I'm
saying I don't think he's like good
enough yeah maybe like she actually
likes him no that can't be that can't be
it's Hollywood if there's so many like
divorces coming out now like with Iran
Jen Garner
oh yeah Jen Garner but it seems like
everybody knew about the Jen garner
thing because remember when we were
watching daily pop and they were like
she's definitely like gonna date a
businessman step outside hope they get
like the whole were like the whole
industry knows but it's like no unless
she gives the exclusive to people we
can't see there we can really can't talk
about it like why not
no she's definitely in gate so my
chopping her mic totally I'm just trying
to be where she's definitely engaged for
sure Jennifer Garner but I also think
like she's the type she's like a
Courtney in the sense like she really
cares about her kids and I think that
like she just wants to make sure that
she has her priorities in order
right because like that's just the way
she wants to live her life and that's
just like important to me
yeah the way you're literally like so
skinny in real life
really yeah oh my god thing you and your
looked ham let me take off my ski
goggles for a second where'd you get a
tan sugared in bronze you know what ever
since I got like a premium a premium tan
I don't it's perfect for this yeah but
we need to schedule our tans for I know
and now you don't have to like and I
also need to get a jumpsuit for
Nashville let's go shopping I have an
appointment tomorrow Bloomingdale's
well my stylist is coming over to pull
some looks for me to take pictures and
in Positano which is honestly like you
look like a clown like I'm like I'm not
trying to be mean but like we need to
get the photo and with your [ __ ] like
leather skirt and your turquoise
eyeshadow like you look like a [ __ ]
dog I like how I look and that's fine
but like we're here for like the easy
photo shoot and like Connie is gonna be
so pissed if like there's a [ __ ]
clown in the background like we're not
at the [ __ ] circus but what how can
you say that in front of everyone who's
worked so hard to put this look together
for me of black pants and a black top
like they worked so hard and you have no
respect and I know they're people's
feelings but like I don't care like you
look like a [ __ ] clown like do you
know how many people it took to pull
this top off the rack okay I'm sorry
and there and I'm sorry for how I said
it but like you
look like a [ __ ] lab I mean I just
flew all this way I didn't need to come
here just like I thought it was gonna be
a fun sister's trip like Making Memories
having our priorities in order
ya know and like there's time for that
like we will we will dedicate a day to
getting our priorities in order but like
for right now like I need you to like
pull it together like look chic do not
wear those [ __ ] Wyatt steel strappy
sandals like come on we flew all the way
[ __ ] here for it I mean I just I
can't like you are just someone who I
don't want to be around and that's fine
cuz you're a [ __ ] lunatic and she's
you're a lunatic like get the [ __ ] out
but I have a business to run like we're
all so busy and like we have to revolve
all our schedules around you like stop
with your [ __ ] YSL sandals I mean I'm
going on vacation with the kids and and
that's your priority and that's fine
but you and your [ __ ] lunatic
therapist can grab a spoon and eat my
ass Wow
you've been watching way too much of the
morning toast it's like you're obsessed
with that show wait I have to tell you
something like over the weekend I was
honored at this gala and I met the
craziest girl she like kept saying like
she's like I'm a girl with no job and
I'm like I don't know what that means
and I was literally let me I was
applying my publicist that's good I was
my publicist like he was not saying like
this girl was crazy like and I didn't
want to be rude and like oh like she was
so crazy this girl so she doesn't have a
job yeah I guess like I didn't really
know what was coming on but then on
Instagram I saw like a million people
tagging me in this photo like she has a
lot of influence and like a lot of
Instagram followers I was thinking about
following her I just feel like I don't
know I feel like you just need to be
using like you're like following in just
a more positive way where like you know
you're you have your priorities in order
yeah um so I don't know like that's just
not something I would do for my life
right but it's your life so yeah cuz
you're a [ __ ] lunatic get the [ __ ]
out oh my god my wig is hurting my wig
is over Joan Jett oh my dad
I don't know how she does it I know well
it's always yeah I know it's the wig
headache like my cat you know how she
does what my wig is too tight
oh look amazing can how much do we have
to pay you to wear that every day no
just to go to class today like that I'm
going away seriously we'll pay you what
would it take
I'm not going to my class you consider
your bonus you please please mom please
it's like one thing I literally could
never because today would be the one day
run into everyone I know
no but it's also Halloween so like you
haven't no it's true you could mom
please mom please like just do this one
thing for us literally like so unfair
cuz I don't do enough for you know like
dad would have wanted it this way
well we're seeing a man what are you
talking about literally had the most
pleasant childhood like we couldn't have
been more rich and famous and like it
was all wonderful like how could you say
that that's so hurtful I mean it's just
like I just can't believe that she did
that to us right like what though just
like was a mom like being a mom being
there for us providing like marrying
like a really great new husband and like
all of that was just so hard on me and
mom I want you to be really honest with
us like when was last time you saw Todd
waters like I couldn't even tell you did
snitch know who Todd waters is yes it's
Who I am
do you had on Roberts senior with I just
like I'm kind of with Courtney on this
one like I just think it's like
incredibly [ __ ] up that you two still
communicate we don't communicate but
like we saw pictures of you know you
didn't but like I did
well and we also saw our pictures of you
with Todd kraines my husband that's okay
he's our neighbor well we saw pictures
that's just had otherwise well probably
he's calling you every day yeah yes came
in art vandal a hard man we should have
had someone else I was totally Oh
my [ __ ] head is killing between these
tiny sunglasses I bought it [ __ ]
Dwayne Reed this morning I had a
traumatic I had a traumatic experience
said to me this morning and everyone
thinks I'm being crazy what happened we
have to say story hands by my other life
and like I must do you know I don't know
where it could be and like I don't want
to start like I'm making announcement
that I'm putting the martini down
because it's hurting my head I mean you
should probably stop drinking at some
point mom it's not organic 95 5 o'clock
somewhere and it's not gluten-free and
like how can you just how can you live
your life like that
alright by the way so much has happened
since the last time we did the show like
I've totally forgot oh my god I know
that was in Boston it's been like a full
week I have to tell you the craziest
thing that happened to this morning and
I feel weird saying it in this costume
because it's a serious story and like I
was so traumatized like and luri had
diarrhea
I want to drain me this morning to buy
my special sunglasses and these socks
and I'm just like browsing the sock
aisle and I was actually taking a look
at the granny panties selection because
they had a wonderful row and literally
this man in the aisle comes like walking
towards me fast and he's like so weird
and like monotone and like look amigos
are you Jewish and I'm like we're with
this in Duane Reade and like in what
city here in here yeah this morning and
I was like yeah I'll just worry about
myself
pay attention Polly no but you were
talking about your weekend like you had
to tell sorry
going on I have listened to myself I
have to pick up my kids from school in
six hours I don't know how long I can
listen to her story so this man comes
darting down the aisle and he's like are
you Jewish he's wearing a yarmulke okay
so I was like and like if you're Jewish
you know like old like rabbis they're
like weird and friendly and they're like
they always want to teach you a lesson
or something like at first I was like
yeah and then it like dawned on me like
what happened this weekend and I was
like freaking out and he was like really
live where you from and I was like what
and that with my heart was beating so
fast I'm asking I'm just I'm from
Brooklyn
what shul do go to and it was like KJ
it's like asking me 1 million questions
about the rabbi I was my heart was
beating so fast I didn't I was like born
ringing online wanting to like lead and
like not be rude inkay seems just like a
nice Jewish man like right that's a
great it sounds weird but like if you're
Jewish like you know rabbis are like
weird and friendly and like talk to
everyone they have lessons to teach you
right but like these days like you never
know and like I was so scared I really
thought I was gonna die like I was like
oh he's death to the Jews Oh like the
guy in Pittsburgh like I was [ __ ]
shaking freaking out and I just like
started to walk away and like he
realized he was like scaring me and
walked away also and it was like the
first time in my entire life I was ever
like afraid to be Joey she was so scary
that's so weird I wonder what he wanted
I know he didn't want anything like I
think he was just like I don't know
that's so weird it was so scary like I
need like that doesn't sound supposed to
happen in New York
no because but it's but he was Jewish so
he was just like I guess I don't know
but I never would have had that thought
process like never pizza from Pittsburgh
yeah well cuz it was like a very like
Jewish town where it happened yeah I
don't know I was like freaking out sorry
to bring the move down I just wanted to
share like I literally my heart was
beating so it's either like the most
benign thing ever and it's just like a
friendly do or like it wasn't really I
meant we it was a benign thing but like
the way it made me feel I've never felt
before you know yeah that's so scary but
like so scary weird but like nothing
happened like what area Matt I don't
know no no right there was nothing
really scary about it but like just like
the climate made me feel the way I've
never felt before it was so scary like I
was literally like about to cry when my
girl walked into Duane Reade she was
freaking out good thing your mom came in
and it was fine yeah yeah thank God no
one ever do a good job at being a mom
mom thank you
least favorite daughter Chris who is
your least favorite daughter Courtney
okay
why because she's always ragging on me
and doesn't appreciate the things that
I've done for her and the life that I've
given her yeah I feel like lately like
your guys's relationship is definitely
strained having a lot to do with the
fact that you're a [ __ ] lunatic and
like it makes me really sad like I
really wish you guys would just like
talk it out work it out and I don't know
just do better well I'm open to doing
better but I feel like you're not I I am
like all I want is just like have a
dialog and get our priorities like in
order okay like maybe I should sit down
like not yours is better than actual
licensed doctor what's wrong with my
therapist I don't know she's a [ __ ]
lunatic
okay next story is honestly one that I
really personally relate to someone said
that every time they cut to this Chris
cam but if you're listening to today's
episode as a podcast I highly encourage
you it's only for the Chris cam yeah no
truly only for the Chris can the crew
like wait you didn't answer our question
seriously how much would that we have to
pay you to go to class like that like
honestly my $500 wasn't over $100 know
what because she's like rich these days
why cause she's making that 10% of your
tour right thousand dollars you guys
coasters like everyone who's watching
right now only needs to give like 30
cents and we'll get there if I gotta
$500 I would go to class but you want to
flex you 50 nope okay fine okay we'll
think about it uh this next story I just
really like relate to on a personal
level
mm-hmm Jon Bon Jovi slams Kim Kardashian
and reality TV Jon Bon Jovi isn't a fan
of reality TV it's many characters or
the theme obsessed culture we live in
quote I think it's horrific that we live
in a world and I can tell you I've never
given 60 seconds of my life ever to one
of those Housewives of blah blah and
Kardashians this the rocker ranted on
Australia is the Sunday Project the
Access Hollywood quote I don't know
their names a 56 year old added I've
never watched 60 seconds of the show
it's not for me but living on a prayer
rockers aware of Kim Kardashian's
existence however and her unconventional
rise to fame quote what's gonna be in
your autobiography
I made a porno and guess what I got
famous [ __ ] sorry
I'll pass he suggested that fame seeker
should find another route to the top
quite go and write a book quote go and
write a book paint a painting act study
sing play write Bon Jovi explained
having a kid tell me quote I want to be
famous and say why Fame is a byproduct
of writing a good song
what a [ __ ] lunatic look he doesn't
even know us I mean I agree
with him wait out of character I really
[ __ ] hate when people brag on the
Kardashian I was like for no reason like
okay I'm sure it's annoying for John
Bongiovi who like is talented and worked
his whole life to like get where he is
like that's definitely annoying between
the fountain and works your whole life
even though I hate her and she's mainly
super sister and she's so selfish she
does not have her priorities in order
he's a hard-working man I get white Bon
Jovi would like feel the way that he
feels and everyone's entitled to their
own feelings but I like doing it
publicly in an interview like as a man
in today's climate like just don't like
just Tom and I can't even go into like
the whole argument as to why I like Kim
is like a talented smart businessperson
cuz I've gone into it so many times and
like I can't but when when someone does
this first of all like you're showing
your age like you obviously just don't
understand like the climate that we live
in and like the world that we live in
and that's fine but like you're making
yourself look like old and just like
bitter so just stop John oh please also
like dude you know I found out Jon Bon
Jovi's name is John Bongiovi like he's
he's Italian and his last name is bun
Jovi you guys I'm getting memos stop
vagina returning can you make your gun
really private everyone no you can't and
I tried but if you ever been mummy eyes
donated all today SPCA like every month
they donate $100 Hathi oh why did why
did that SPCA make you think about the
oh this is a dog he's fantastic
just like in such good spirits he's
definitely lost a little bit of weight
which is good because his breed is
predisposed to heart conditions so
anytime they gain weight it's like
terrible for their health I'll be
bringing him over later today to my
apartment for the fifth and final
patreon oh well no but I guess yeah
October 31st is today so it's yesterday
for fifth and final patreon we should do
that whole episode with just on the
Chris cam totally um personally this
story just makes a lot of sense to me
like ever since I've been with unis and
stuff like he just really feels like our
whole careers are [ __ ] and that like
we we are just such a negative influence
on society by the way Jon Bon Jovi was
talking about you to like I just I feel
like Jon Bon Jovi and I like have I have
our priorities in order
you know I guess but like you know we
get out of character for this yeah I
hate when people brag on the Kardashians
it like makes me so I don't every time I
get out of character I take my glasses
off you know that's how you guys know
we're in character out of character
that's what it you pay that should be
you know it's just like I hate when
people it's like so it's like the
easiest argument like you want to seem
intelligent like rag against the
Kardashians when it's like actually the
opposite like they are business women
specials they're all billionaires like
in their own right and I just get
annoyed when people come for them like
please stop please stop but I have an
original thought that's not original
that's like so 2011 we like the
Kardashian down 2018 move on yeah and
she's more than a sexy like anyone can
have a sex tape seriously go make one oh
and by the way and anyone has had snow
and like go make a sex tape and then
become Kim Kardashian like right see
tell me how easy it is you know go make
a sex tape and then literally have every
designer in the world dying to make your
custom bridal gown are you caught up no
keeping up I'm behind on every single TV
show me I wonder then I'd be like your
day'll Dallas Kardashian's you only
really need to keep up John I serve on
dynasty show on TV
Kardashians i watch last night it was
you didn't miss like that much next week
is the episode where without rain Oh
Tristan what the hell is elsewhere
Johnson I don't know she'll be shows
they keep teasing us mad sneak is true
is the Tristan
Hoka third trimester TMZ Tristan third
trimester Thompson this episode we just
had her baby shower I I did show up for
this baby shower well that was
thoughtful I just felt like it was
important to me um it was literally the
most extravagant baby shower of all time
and it's like when it was on when they
get all these like flowers and stuff
like Kylie posted like a huge orange
flower arrangement from Jeff Letha I'm
like and they're so amazing like don't
get me wrong and now I really do sound
like corny but like all the flowers that
Chloe's baby shower like it's so we're
out of character it's so like waste I
know I heard what that I mean I'm sure
they donate them afterwards like
hospitals and stuff and I think that
they give to their assistants like
everyone takes something home but it's
like a Chloe's shower was so over the
top yeah because it was sponsored by the
way okay by Amazon and also because like
this is years in the making of her
deserves this she deserves the biggest
best shower of the
I definitely agree but I see where the
wastefulness company was just like
feeling like they had a they had
elephants like life-sized elephant's
made out of flowers like that's wild
there are I figure the company's called
but it's like they come to your wedding
Bar Mitzvah whatever at the end and take
the flowers and ring them to the
hospital and like to live it up to
patients yeah and I'm sure that's what
the Kardashians do I'll see a lot of the
flowers that they have are forever
flowers and a lot of them are also fake
yeah but like if they last year like
that's not wasteful and donating them is
really helpful but like they had just
got so many flowers it's getting a
little crazy yeah no it definitely it's
that's like a celebrity thing now they
like made that a trend yeah like I just
floral but honestly like I'm here for it
like oh wow like usually celebrities
like diamonds like chains etc they're
like no we're gonna make flowers cool
speaking of jelly thumb him and Colton
Haynes like got married by Kris she was
the minister good job man and then
months later or not
Yeah right Leslie announced they were
getting divorce and then like a couple
days ago they were like happy
Anniversary love you like it was nowhere
near wedding anniversaries so weird I
don't know what's going on so weird yeah
but I think they're cute couple I want
them to stay together me too
I was so upset when I heard they got
divorce I know okay let's like hold out
hope he did Khloe's baby shower too with
him he does all the Kardashians it's to
me
good stuff good stuff um episode last
night was okay but then Scott like goes
to Cleveland to hang out with Khloe and
they brought back their podcast which
they started in the Hamptons which is
hilarious it was being really annoying
but they really should do a podcast like
that would you so where did they release
it I don't think they ever did they were
just like recording all over town they
should totally do it it's like if you do
one Episode a week and you're doing it
with another co-host it's like not that
much work ever it's an hour of you time
if you're called a Kardashian you make a
ton of money right cuz like everyone
would want to sponsor it and like um no
one really cares what you say like so
just talk for an hour
totally oh they should totally do except
don't like don't infiltrate our space
now I hate when like traditional
celebrities do podcasts cuz like
obviously you're gonna get a lot of
listen sometimes you like I feel like
Khloe would actually be an amazing
podcast in like the Amy Schumer podcast
I'm like not here for it for so many
reasons I can't bash a podcast honestly
until I listen to it like oh say my
nails and I once stood guard that Anna
Faris won and yeah I couldn't get
through a few minutes because like there
were babies crying in the backyard and
that's just not good about that
and the toasters are really good like
Isis them judges of podcast cuz they are
like the ideal podcast audience like if
someone releases the podcast it's
basically for the toasters and they gave
really good feedback on Amy Schumer's
when they were like it's so bad like you
show up be at a million dollars from
Spotify to do it so like obviously
that's the only reason she sat down and
there's like three other co-host it's
like so confusing and it's just like she
your heart has to be in it and Amy's
heart wasn't in it she was in it for the
money which I would have obviously don't
have season two yeah she made a million
dollars when it's gonna be season two of
this show I was gonna say do we do
seasons now we'll do it by here like an
April we'll start season two like well
maybe just 2019 we start season two
perhaps yes I'm getting itchy
up in here you know like my the back of
my head yeah me too oh my god okay let's
get through yeah
next story Barbra Streisand's honest
review of a star is born may surprise
you introducing Barbra Streisand the
movie critic it's no secret that the
majority of critics and moviegoers alike
are impressed with the star is born
starting late starring Lady gaga and
Bradley Cooper so that's our girls no
job in fact the film continues to
receive Oscar buzz and it's only October
13 of did you see Nina Dobrev smile Jim
what what was it okay this is why I got
it it was a a star being born as a baby
so she had like baby toys I think the
cage around her was um I forgot so it
was like creative and stupid until the
cage the cage again so campaigning for
an Oscar like for because daddy the
Joker making or is the born in painting
for Best Picture as hard as it's
campaigning for an Oscar for Lady Gaga
yeah it's not the best picture sorry no
and no offense she wasn't the best
actress no but she should get nominated
but she shouldn't win she will get
nominated and she won't win great yeah
cuz the Oscars are nothing if not fair
and balanced but for some pop culture
fans they want to know what the cast of
the 1976 don't think about the new
remake Believe It or Not Barbara hasn't
seen the entire version just yet at the
same time she likes what she has seen
thus far quote I haven't seen it
completed Bradley did show me the
opening I was surprised by how similar
it was to my version she shared with a
new shines the drag bar I thought that
was new and interesting what I've seen
it of the film I really liked she's so
shy day first of all by not having seen
it in full right that's
the insult she could in her saying like
oh I liked it she didn't even see it so
you don't whatever she says after that
is irrelevant it's a she meant as a shed
a common right and her saying like so
similar to mine first of all like I only
could get through the first ten minutes
of hers and it was so painful she is so
annoying as I've said and like I don't
want to bash or too much because like I
know so many people respect her and I'm
not trying to tell you like I don't have
a horse in this race you know I just
like like have a little respect for the
lady I agree you know what I mean for
the gags and like she's really like
picked up your baton and like has ADD
like kept it going she likes
I bet she's brought a lot of like like a
respect and elegance and gravitas to an
important role right and and I'm sure so
many people watched Barbara's movie
because of it like me I rented it well
she got that chance Lady Gaga is rising
your star again right so can't we all
just get along and not be shunned a it's
like impossible for these people to not
be shunned I know I know and it's like
even I think Barbra Streisand really
thought she was being nice but like
she's so inherently like jealous you
know yeah and like full of herself I
wanted to ask you a question and I know
I missed a lot and I watch the episodes
that I miss but I never got to discuss
the wicked 15th anniversary with you yes
yesterday me and mom talked about it
surprising mom what did you think I
thought it was like incredible I thought
Kristin Chenoweth was unbelievably
annoying
idina menzel I didn't like that she
changed his song but ariana grande was
truly stole the show stole the show so
meet you el trovador in Ghana in a
second I want to talk about idina menzel
and her wild disappointment up a
performance of defying gravity because I
think of the whole special I was
obviously most excited to hear to find
gravity and to be honest I wanted it to
be Lea Michele and the only thing that
special was missing was Emilia Michelle
presents like the head out of I've ever
agreed but like that is hurt song right
but they should have had Lea Michelle
sing something else but and I read
something afterwards because I had to do
research like they did this weird
Starbucks jazz CD arrangement of defying
gravity it was like sooo it was so
terrible
she couldn't it was like the arrangement
was made for all the notes to get rid of
all the notes that are difficult or high
and I read somewhere that because idina
menzel has had to sing to find gravity
and let it go so many times and there's
so whatever she got notes so she can't
really sing those songs anymore so I
guess while they were being respectful
and giving
a song like for the sake of the
performance like let Lea Michele have it
but she sounded good she sounded
horrible the range house I hear she
sounded good I didn't like the
arrangement and it oh yes
the arrangement was arranged for her new
voice right but she her new voice
sounded good and I thought she still
she's still sounding ready to sounded
like they were trying to make change the
songs like update it make it be a little
more pop no she can't sing it anymore
because of her nodes well that's sad for
her like don't ruin the special bring
this on Michele and I was like really
disappointed
the for good she was good in for good
because there was 10 people with her and
she didn't have to do anything but I
have watched The Wizard and I with
Ariana Grande I can't even tell you on
the plane on the car ride home literally
this morning I must have watch it
anytime we sit on Spotify did have to
release it on Spotify she was incredible
first of all second bow I loved her
festive lid I don't love the shirt but I
like to make up SC oh I loved her look
like actually you know what I didn't
like like I loved her top but she was my
knee with leg legs yeah weird
I thought the top was a little ill and
like that top was definitely custom like
everything else she wears like she
should have made that into a mini dress
yes I would have looked so [ __ ] cute
her makeup was so cute and that she wore
that super cute necklace like from the
neck up I was feeling her she was having
the time of her life on the stage like
she was she is really like a theater
nerd she was she started in 13 with Liz
Gillies like you just know and her
brother loves the like a Broadway like I
think that her her vibe is very Broadway
so like she was having the time of her
life she was smiling and she was even
though she was having a hard day cuz
that was the day after yeah and she's
wearing the bad day to cover up the
tattoo and I wasn't even thinking about
that like I was not even like she didn't
make me realize like how was sad of a
day I supposed to be for her she was
just out there singing her heart out and
I was really getting to thinking like
I've always been a fan of Ariana like I
love her her like a lot of things about
her but like she really is like I would
say the vocalists of our generation I
agree and then I was getting some
feedback on Instagram from that and the
reason why I'm asking is like who do you
think is a more talented vocalist
just voice her or Lady Gaga oh um it's
tough they're so different
I'm inclined to say ariana grande so she
can do more but there's nothing she
can't do
I think thought was more of an artist
lage yes and Lady got is more um yeah
like she can arrange anything to make
herself out
she sounds amazing but I do think that
ariana grande is like the vocal talent
of our time and and and I think she gets
that respect like Bridget beauty and the
beast' remakes and she reads the
Franklin's funerals right like Celine
Dion seeing beauty in the beasts like
who's the Celine Dion of our generation
it's ariana grande and I think that the
industry recognizes that but that makes
me happy you know yeah I don't think
that her new music I like her name is ik
it doesn't reflect the type of voice
that she has and they the closest we got
to like what her best music was it's
like dangerous women like into you vibe
yeah cuz like it was very uh I don't
love her new music and maybe I haven't
just spent enough time on it but I would
be good for like I come in like about yo
I totally agree it just it's not even
it's not soulful enough like she member
this like weird like EDM and they breath
loud yeah yeah like she is so such
goddess woman was a great vibe for the
album but nothing else sounds I got as a
woman yeah and no tears left to cry like
you hear nothing you like it but it's
just nothing like spectacular about any
of it and you know who I blame
Pete Davidson me to divide because that
was the defeat album yeah also like and
I only was bringing up the ariana grande
question because people were disagreeing
with me but I many more so like I don't
think Ariana has the best like songs or
lyrics and she writes her own songs like
I just was talking about strictly voice
strictly voice ariana artist overall
Lady Gaga a little bit yeah oh I
actually it's really tough day but let's
write their own music no not even one is
better than the other I'm just I wanted
to put her in the ringer oh it's hard
they both write their own music vocally
Lady gaga stronger than Taylor Swift yes
and lyrically Taylor Swift is stronger
than Lady Gaga melodically Lenny because
Lea has really in there like with the
drums and yeah but you know I got has
been work yes and then Lady Gaga can
dance oh yeah I'm Taylor Swift can but
you know what she's trying she's trying
and she knows she can't dance and I
appreciate that you know who else
couldn't dance ariana grande and she
doesn't anymore
yeah like when she was she just on me
know what she does is she walks around
sees yeah and then slips her hair and
she used to do a couple moves with the
dancers and she it wasn't it she was a
bit sir it's like she had no energy
which is weird because she's like tiny
you know but it's because she's tiny she
has
and she was just like not interested in
performing the moves properly and she
doesn't do it anymore well I saw her in
concert and literally she just wore a
huge sweatshirt that was like off her
shoulder so she couldn't even like move
right with enormous boots and just like
walked around and sat around the stage
honestly now that I think about it was
disappointing but because Little Mix
opened um I had the time of my life
I love Little Mix meteo except that they
got involved in I know Jackie I had
glitter I was about to say the same like
I'm so disappointed in that meet you
because I believe Cardini when she says
she was offered the diesel deal and the
woman like me song she said she was
offered women like that's woman like me
that's what this whole thing was yeah I
thought Little Mix was just jumping in
to be like heart like cardi B says she's
offered all these songs first and then
woman and then Little Mix jumped in to
say what we offered making this song so
her teammate went on to another rampage
and the one thing she said she said you
diesel deal like I couldn't accept it
because I have so many conflicting
things and then they offered it to me
first and woman like me and the girls
put up a screenshot of their whatsapp
group and was like let's get Nicki which
doesn't prove anything they could have
already been rejected by cardi they also
could have just written that like right
now yeah so like it seemed like they
were just doing it because they wanted
to like align with Nicki Minaj for the
sake of the song right now we're talking
about the song and it's not that great I
haven't heard it I don't really care I
really am like hating Nicki Minaj these
days I think she's like such a [ __ ] and
so entitled and I think I don't even
know the extent of the fight with cardi
but like I just take cardi B side cuz
like it's so obvious that like Nicki
Minaj took a year off and she says she
was in rehab and like cardi B just blew
up and the reason why people are like
there's no rapper female rappers it's
cuz Nicki Minaj bullies them out but
cardi B won't she won't she won't laugh
at man she will not let me she will not
let herself be bullied I think and you
know I respect that I like I'm hating
Nicki Minaj she just needs to like get
out lighten up no one like she's an icon
already right look no Hardy B is
nominated for new artists of the year
like you are an icon you could be
getting the Vanguard
you need not be fighting with her like
you give her so much more like respect
and you you bring yourself to her level
well that whether that's elevating cardi
to your level or going down to her level
of new artists like now you guys are on
the same level if you're fighting with
each other and like that is not where
you need to be and that's better
brant it is it is I agree and like this
is only good for cardio and also like
I'm I am team cardi in this but like I
do still like Nikki so well no I'm a
really locating here Oh Chris what do
you think you talked about this
yesterday I really can't stand Nikki I
know I only like the week that's what I
was saying what do you like her pink
print album lady to Romans revenge
yes base yeah well right did she gave us
so much no no her musics great I'm not
saying anything about her music I'm just
saying her as a person I think she's
like a mean girl I agree you're a mean
girl you're a [ __ ]
okay fifth and final story which
ordinarily I wouldn't make news but I
just think it's so pertinent to the
culture Justin Bieber lookalike
ate a burrito sideways as part of an
elaborate hoax it's time to lay off
Justin Bieber the Canadian pop star had
Internet users news outlets and other
celebrities around the world in a tizzy
on Thursday when photos of a man
appearing to be him eating a burrito
sideways emerged online however it turns
out a Bieber lookalike named Brad Souza
was the one actually responsible for
eating the dish all wrong and he's
outrageous act was part of an elaborate
hoax
Susa was hired by a company called yes
theory and flew from Canada LA to
participate in the Sun which included
various engineered to go viral scenarios
including the burrito bit and an
instance in which soos addresses Bieber
helped a grandma for hire across the
street of course we didn't see that
picture go back I didn't even see that
neither we wanted to prove a point
that's staging a story as goofy as it
was can be done much more easily than
most people can imagine that's not the
point the point here is that this our
society is literally so dumb yeah a
picture of a Justin Bieber eating a
burrito wrong turn the world upside down
right and like honestly good for these
guys for like you can try and make
something go viral and you can plan it
to the whatever like you can't make
something go viral like it has that
viral effect like good for them for
actually making a goal but it actually
seems as though uh they had a the
picture had a slow start on reddit and
then they eventually made it to the
front page of the site which were later
picked up my news publications autonomy
Fair which attempted to verify the
photos and in news it's like no one even
cares what the truth is anymore
right this person looks like Justin
Bieber in welding a burrito like a [ __ ]
thank you so much for saying that and
which brings me to the only reason I
wanted to talk about this story like I
don't really care that the picture was
fake I don't care when it was real all
right is I want to smell so happy that
like we didn't even
I never need a look like morons right
which brings me to my point of wanting
to talk about the story I didn't watch
any of the new programs on e I wanted to
watch the lady gang what I didn't yet
but I didn't watch busy tonight but from
my understanding it was not good
yeah and I my understanding from the
toaster yeah my understanding was that
the episode was split up into like a
couple segments like a few segments and
one of the big segments a spoke about
was this picture of Justin Bieber but
they pre record because I guess they
don't wanna do it live or whatever and
the news had broke that it was fake but
the episode didn't address that it was
making because it was recorded a few
days before and I just like that is just
the perfect shining example but what's
wrong with me and like the fact that
they're not in tune with what's
necessary like you have a ton of money
reshoot the episode or get rid of that
segment like it was and by the way
please someone confirm that this is true
and that they actually did not address
that it was a fake photo but like are
you kidding me like that's so
embarrassing
no it's so embarrassing also it's a late
night show that's not live what's the
point right I don't need to talk about
days old news yeah I you know what I
think a lot of the problem with these
programming is it's like they have like
every minute scheduled like we talked
about this at 1101 and 1102 minutes to
change to this game like they can't let
people free free fall which is why daily
pop is still good because they let
Morgan and Justin just like [ __ ] talk
yeah and that's whites good because
they're both and I want to watch a
nightly pop now it premiered sorry I
want to watch nightly pop now I can
watch busy tonight on lady games just
like know what's going on and like how
these digital people are representing us
right on traditional TV and like if
we're ever gonna get a shot because of
that right now I didn't hear as many bad
things about lady gang as I did busy
tonight people like lady gang and I want
to I want to see it honestly I only wish
them the best because proof of concept
right like what's good for podcast is
good for us and what's good for female
podcast is even better for us right um
but I do yeah when I get home I'm gonna
I've so much programming to catch up on
same I didn't even realize I have to
watch busy tonight and Lady game but
she's on four nights a week like how was
the second episode shut up yeah Sunday
Monday Tuesday Wednesday or something
like that like it's still been going on
but people only talking about the first
episode so Thank You Cassandra
apparently they addressed that the photo
is fake on their Instagram stories
that's so embarrassing
here's some toaster recaps of both shows
busy tonight is okay it was better in
the second episode lady gang was good
too but both seems to so staged
that's a tease problems like they're so
worried their programs aren't gonna work
because they never do that they have
planned on every minute did stage every
second commercial and it's like just if
you like the talent enough enough to
give them a show like let them free ball
for a while right and like especially
with a podcast like lady game that's
what they like this is how they decay
being hired them like let them do what
they do it's busy it's different because
like no one knows exactly where it's
going so I feel like they need that
structure yeah I don't know what
happened to play-by-play apparently was
only supposed to be three episode test
run and to see how it did like it was
never a hold I thought that if it did
well they were gonna record a rap stones
and keep it going oh I don't know how
are you supposed to tell if his show is
doing well in three episodes it's not
fair like dynasty at the beginning of
last year nobody watched right but we
knew it was amazing but actually was
already filmed so right so you would
actually lose more money not putting it
out right play-by-play like happens
based off of like real events and the
new episodes yeah but all these shows
would really benefit from being live
like I couldn't agree more there's not
really don't trust your talent enough to
go live it there's nothing like
programming people can't do it it's
crazy even some of the jimmies are
pre-taped yeah all of them all Jimmy
Kimmel Live is not but Jimmy Fallon is
always pre-taped what's the other James
Corden is pre-taped I've been catching
James Corden Jack Zak just like has it
on randomly this past week and it's like
so disappointing every time I see it I'm
so bored they're playing the dumbest
game like I don't under
wild to me because I love him so much
well I've never really watched his show
I just watched all his clips on YouTube
and I feel like that's enough for me
I don't need an hour every night like I
watch the carpool karaoke with Michael
Buble and had so many thoughts oh my god
Michael Buble like is an amazing singer
but his mouth when he sings is the
weirdest thing ever he is like so many
weird like and then when the dad was
playing the saxophone and Michael Buble
was trying to like scat with it he was
like that'd I like wanted to punch him
in the face he was making me feel so
uncomfortable but James Corden's dad is
so funny trying at Michael bublé's
number and James Corden was like if you
get Mike to Michael Buble if you give my
dad your phone number he'll text you
every day if that brings it it was so
funny like it was never a cute episode
like I'm I think it's so weird who they
choose to do for carpool karaoke cuz
it's obvious that they
they were like we want icons only right
but there's so many icons who haven't
gotten the opportunity and I think
there's so many icons that won't do it
they also need to take what they can get
Britain if you're not a good live singer
they're not gonna write but Selena Gomez
did it but she didn't hurt James Corden
is the most amazing singer and they sang
together the whole time but like SIA oh
my god also you do lip-sync for a lot of
it like SIA was the greatest one like
her [ __ ] voices Michele was amazing
yeah obviously One Direction oh my god I
watched that one shine and we got a
Harry Styles right yes and the Harry
Styles one was incredible - yeah but who
hasn't gotten one that like will
telltale a bit like she's so reserved
because everyone so meet her she'll
never do it no we have Ariana yes oh yes
she's always on James Corden yes she
just we watched it was so funny
really they did like this like Haunted
escape room and that's how she heard a
hand yeah oh my god it was hilarious
okay who else hasn't done one they did
Celine Dion Barbra Streisand comes out
with one this week right you know what
I'm gonna watch it worse you are Jo
because if there's anything that's gonna
show her in a positive light and like
the best side of her yes carpool karaoke
so like if I like it I'll give her a
second chance
oh my god I saw Maddie Ziegler at a
party this weekend and like it was just
so weird like how old is she right and I
was like oh do you want to tell us about
your big weekend in Hollywood I forgot
that like it's been so long since I've
been here I didn't see you since Boston
no I know but I feel like she does see
you like in real life no we just like
we're face oh yeah I haven't seen I got
him Friday and then I went to LA
Saturday did I see you I went to Austin
on Friday oh right um I haven't seen you
that's so crazy I know I feel like we
know all about with Austin because we
have the behind-the-scenes and since I
put together the video like I really do
feel like I was there no yeah um and it
looked amazing
it was incredible I mean first of all
Boston is the most steamy place ever
like first of all well cause the BAS
team wears number one podcast in Boston
oh my god totally it just totally did
you feel that when we were there were
you walking down the street like hello
welcome to a number one podcast in the
state I didn't remember till the train
ride home I was the number one podcast
in the state so like I was annoyed that
I had forgotten about it we just go to
New Jersey thing here reminders cross
the border but it was so incredible
first of all the vulvar theater is like
the
see she's just like there you can feel
it and like I was just like living for
everything going on like both shows were
just so great like I was great I think
the meet and greets were great there had
such good gifts like maybe maybe some of
my favorite it's like somebody made me a
book like you know we used to make each
other like this Snapfish book yeah so
it's like a collage of pictures of all
of us then the wedding and in every
picture
they had photoshopped a spoon in my hand
hey describe I'm a graphic designer like
this is literally what I do for a living
and like it was so funny and so great
even like it had leaves on the front
like it was so cute not to make it about
myself in any gifts for me um yes some
letters oh that's nice I don't need my
Anthony Ches award Margot give it to
your sister
someone in clue no it was so long ago
no we're we're Albany Albany it was that
it was that it was that like leg of the
tour or whatever maybe whatever someone
made Jackie like in etched in glass
skull major award an Oscar that was like
presented to Jacqueline ra for her role
in his knee chest of the an snitch s of
the year the number one and in this
group and they made a smaller one for
Margo that said the number one snitch
his lair was home don't you and Marta
took the boat home and never gave it
right she's stealing my award must be
cool it must be nice but I am don't even
get me started well so then so it was
honestly like the greatest night of my
life like and like playing the Wilbur is
like a big deal like everyone like it's
talking about it like in the industry
and I'm like yeah I did play well
bertrise yeah and the countess is gonna
be there next month also like we have to
go yeah we'll be back Boston and she's
doing to your two shows also um but the
weirdest thing so the night after the
show like first of all someone said mark
it looks like the lead singer of Green
Day that's so true oh my god you look
like chilli like Billy Joel yeah sure
yes yes teracle well though on our
Instagram above Taylor slide show of all
the people you look like thanks
Christian including grease day oh my god
hysterical I'm doing an email confirming
anything cuz the week it's fallen like
me
[Laughter]
oh you are literally the funniest person
ever get rid of that way forever I want
to see your eyes I believe I um and by
the way I met so many teens in Boston
well like we've known forever like og
Vance Taylor do Oreo huh and she wanted
me to tell you that she says hello
and also I told her that I would tell
the sanitorium sighs hello I told her I
would say this on the show says actually
I raised her but like when you pick
should Taylor G Oreo like what did you
think she looked like dirty brown hair
um Jenny blonde you dirty dirty blonde
hair
I mean average chesty busty as [ __ ] sure
she's like the smallest frame and the
biggest tits I was like oh my god
they're huge
oh thank you what is your picture I
don't not that you know yeah okay I just
I met so many OG like a fans that like
we needed to meet also we sold merch for
the first time which was so exciting we
sold out of like a couple of items that
I will now I don't know if I'm gonna
bring merge to every show cos it's
annoying but I figure I also have like a
website like leave it up like if you're
coming to a show like get a sweatshirt
yeah I got to give merch should we tell
her no something exciting but we but now
you already said it when you read yes
every we can tell but when we're okay so
we won't just know something exciting is
happening
you're gonna really stay and not what it
was like it's get your wallets ready for
her okay sorry whatever forget it get
high
um yeah sometimes yes get hacked there's
a few things actually because no yeah
okay
oh so the weirdest thing happened to me
Thursday night I it was the longest
night ever soundcheck was that three I
didn't get home till 1:00 I was on my
feet all day I was [ __ ] exhausted and
I had them migraine of a century get
home drift off into sleep and I wake up
ten minutes later it like one o'clock I
wake up a 110 and I never went back to
sleep
I was up the entire night I couldn't
sleep it was like Marga was getting up
at 7:00 to go to school she took an
early train and I was like it was it was
5:30 and I'm like Marcos to wake up in
an hour
I'm getting my fat ass on her train she
changed me and Benz trained tomorrow
straight at 6:30 and I won't everyone up
at like the track I've done and everyone
to kill me when you go to bed I never do
that like I literally did not sleep the
whole night and I didn't sleep that next
day either I wouldn't hold it and then
that night I went to bed that's like I
didn't you need the sleep it's not weird
sometimes it just happens well someone
told me was a full moon Jamie Lynn
Spears actually Demian told me it was a
full moon and that might be affecting
nicely that's so Jamie classic tell us
about him okay well so let me let me
continue because there's just like a lot
so I got on Friday next day I went to LA
because I had to work but I went a day
early like for Halloween I figured maybe
I'll hit some parties and I went to two
very very cool parties like everyone was
there I thought like staying at a party
oh my god I saw Liz Gillies from dynasty
at party and I was leaving and she was
walking in and like I was gonna like be
like thirst monster cuz we have a mutual
friend our friend Kristin who co-hosts
sometimes I grew that's really not that
thirsty
no but I wasn't gonna run back in
because it wasn't a costume party the
first one so I'd already changed to the
bathroom and left I was gonna run back
into the party to say hi to someone and
I think ladies costume so I went to to
medical parties and I tell you all about
them but here's what I learned
either party was stacked with
celebrities great decorations open bar
and like they were not fun possible I
know when I was like you know what like
that kind of made me feel gonna make
even celebrities like they don't have
fun parties either you know it was like
are you my email do you have fun no one
was having fun everyone's like this
party stinks like oh you think so too me
too
well so what makes a fun party I don't
know it's the people it's like I wish
like stairs right I guess if you don't
like you know every way if everyone
there is cool that they don't know each
other and are not comfortable then like
you know you're not getting gas right so
at the first party um I was being a
major weenie just like I had a drink
anything yet and I was like latching on
to my friend and I didn't know anyone
and like I wasn't interested in speaking
to anyone but Emily Osment was there
that's cool yeah and she was in costume
even though it wasn't a costume party
good for her yeah no I got her Elle
Woods is how her strength yeah I
appreciated her strength during this
difficult time and then the second party
I went to was like star studded AF and
it obviously didn't know anyone and I
was like latching on to my friend and
ASA Gonzalez who we met at the Super
Bowl and who was literally like the
coolest nicest like most beautiful
person ever and like you don't
understand like the way that every man
in a room like looks at her is still
crazy like I remember if I'm the super
I'd be like even that my skinny is
prettiest most beautiful no one would
ever look at me like she's she was in a
latex Catwoman suit like every man wants
to talk to her buy her a drink even
though zopim are like just like a look
at her and I was like I was the same I
was like like I was like latching on to
her because I didn't know anyone and I
just like didn't want to be a freak I
ran
some peeps and i ran into Ennis and it
was just pure magic I didn't know she
was gonna be there she was dressed as a
star was born
she had brown wig on she was wearing
frozen peas on her hand and her husband
who was so honey cute and they're so
cute Taylor was dressed up as Bradley -
Brad Falchuk yeah it's so cute um it was
so cute she was you guys know what I am
like yeah obviously we know what you are
and I was gonna like make a comment
about how like really a star was born
ripped off Kelly canter vibes from
Country Strong but I didn't want to be
controversial enough I'm sure so nice
and so I didn't see me and like I just
can't believe that she likes me so much
and I can do my face I was asked to be
like I'm Claudio girl and she was like
oh my god what are you doing shown LA
and I was like when are you doing this
show and I know you know the comedy
world like the charity world is la is
like a difficult market cause like
there's no like theaters like the Beacon
Theatre like this is so weird yeah it's
either like 5,000 people or 200 at a
comedy improv and like if la is like one
of my biggest cities and I'm not gonna
do eight shows right but I don't want to
like she was like a huge ass thing and
then nobody buys a ticket you know I met
some San Diego toasters this weekend
Santiago yeah and they really want you
to come to San Diego I might would tell
you so here I'm telling you and that you
would do it because you love Santiago
I'm currently booking January through
June of 2019 and I'm planning on hitting
all the cities that I need to hit I will
need to take two weeks off from the
chose to do the West Coast cuz I'm not
flying back and forth a million times
okay I'm gonna take two weeks off and
I'm gonna get on a tour bus and drive
down the coast and do all the cities and
everyone's got to come with me and we'll
bring Theo and it'll be a good time it's
my p.m. on a tour bus scene the site
sphere there um do in the West Coast oh
my god but wait so I was are you gonna
bring oh my god if you go to Texas you
should bring him home oh my god totally
but oh my god that would be so crazy yet
Dallas Houston and other places but on
my microphone my microphone sorry um
Dallas Houston and like all those places
are my top priority and I'm taking care
of it I'm not in charge of my own future
anymore but just like so annoying but
it's been like and it's also a great
excuse like oh you're gonna come to San
Diego it's time I I'm not interested
less again occurs like whenever somebody
wants me to do something that I wanted
to do I'm like I just chose my
management about it like I don't know if
they'll let me but then it's like if I
want to do something no one listens to
me okay so then I'm at this party
talking to nobody and I like lose the
one person than a friend's bath and I'm
like oh my god I got to find them and I
finally found him and I run over he's
talking these two people who are in
costumes and I can't
they are and I turn over and it's sophie
Turner and Joe Jonas and I've met them
you mean it's sophie Turner and Sansa
Stark right so we've met them at
Coachella and I bring them to them like
a hundred times and like they both
follow me on Instagram Utley be like DM
sometimes but it's like awkward like I
always reintroduce myself but like they
are always so nice and like always never
make me reintroduce myself and I turned
and I I didn't realize who it was and
they were like oh and I was like oh it's
just like so nice to be like known by
literally one person and we had a great
time I hung out all night the whole time
I thought he was dressed as Fiona from
Shrek until someone was like what are
you he's like oh I'm her from the show
and I'm like oh you're Santa I literally
thought you were Shrek Fiona and he was
like oh that's funny I guess it looked
like her too I'm like yeah that is the
funniest thing and I told Santa I was
like I'm obsessed with and that's the T
do you know what she does know oh my god
she is this amazing bit on her Instagram
story so much so like now brand sponsors
it like it's so good she like says
controversial things like and she's at a
restaurant that she picks up her tea and
she's like and that's the tea it's so
funny like you have to watch it um and I
was just like living like for finally
making friends and they were like what
again the photo booth and I'm like oh
sure whatever like anything anything of
it next thing you know I'm on GMA CNN
hilarious and like I love it due to the
Daily Mail like nobody wrote like girl
with a job and honestly like I'm
grateful like I don't know what they
would say and I'm not interested like I
just was happy to be there right you
know happy to be included and everyone's
asking did you ask him at Nick and
Priyanka and no I did not I would like
to be invited again to these places that
they're not gonna be like why is your
brother in a fake marriage no but
speaking him they can be on KY like
they're going so hard she way to shoot a
bridal shower at Tiffany's wearing a
wedding dress by of course Marchesa
Georgina Chapman morning saying that she
did nothing wrong she said that yeah
listen no no person wearing the dress
says no no I saw an article on people
but like I really didn't even want to
talk about it cuz it's like so and also
like we can't talk about anything
Priyanka so much because it makes me
someone texted me a picture from her
button messaged me a picture from her
bridal shower almost like this is so sad
like those balloons could have been for
a real bride no but I think they're
gonna get married no I think say - I
don't do all this engagement party
Bridal Show bridal showers the final
thing before the wedding yeah unless
he's Jewish and he's having enough but I
don't think so Priyanka Chopra where
supports Harvey Weinstein's ex by
wearing Marchesa gown quote it's not her
fault oh my god Chopra called the
decision to wear one of Chapman's
Galan's quote women supporting women she
continued to tell
women's wear daily at bumble India's
launch dinner in New York City Monday
night quote Georgina's a friend of mine
and she has been and it's not her fault
and I don't think it's right to take it
out on a self-made woman what somebody
did what somebody in her life self-made
woman I'm sorry I very very high numbers
I'd shown her for years and that was a
beautiful gown and deserved to be worn
by a bride to be and it made me feel
like the print a princess it was the
right choice
oh my god I'm shook for so many reasons
like self-made woman like um when your
husband threatens his victims to wear
your dresses on red carpets like that's
just like I'm not a self-made woman kind
of by but as a self-made woman you know
I know that also like no like she didn't
actually go out and us all people but
like homegirl now like there's no way
that she did it and I can't believe I
can't believe I can't I know can you
believe no no I literally can't believe
no also you know who I met at this party
star studded and like I just introduced
myself as cloudy like nobody cares like
it's really humbling actually to go to
LA like absolutely nobody cares nobody
nobody cares about anyone like yeah
other than themselves anyway so I meant
Isla Fisher and she was with someone I'm
like oh that Sacha Baron Cohen obviously
and he started talking he was British
and I'm like oh no it's not Sacha Baron
Cohen but it was Sacha Baron Cohen is
British that makes sense is it
I was either expecting to talk like
Borat or like just an American or a
burger now yeah like I wasn't expecting
British that is weird right
that's so cute how were they oh my god I
love them and they were hanging out with
Sarah Silverman who like one attain and
she couldn't have a nice sort of me and
she had no idea who I was in like she
felt out of place with everyone I'm like
she was like cattell I did too and we
were just both like that's nice and I
wanted her just to ask me what I did so
I could say I was a comedian but I
wasn't just gonna be like I'm a comedian
you know you know the comedian out here
ya know like but like I wanted her to
ask what she did it but like I liked her
and I didn't like I didn't like her
before just like from her image but like
she was so nice and so cool she'd have
to be I know changing hearts and minds I
know I saw Evan Ross yeah it was very us
he with his wife I was like you guys
don't know this but I'm gonna talk about
all of you on my podcast I think he was
his wife I didn't see him um but I saw
her they have like they never bothered
me until they had a reality show and
it's like why totally it does it no more
to show how is it
I heard nothing she can't be good cuz
that means people aren't even watching
it enough to deem it that it's bad you
know like you know ones that are a good
sign no one even did the research the
foster sisters were there obviously I
submit Erin fosters a new boyfriend he's
so cute and so nice and like loves how
crazy she is you know who is he
I just a guy I know Jim cute yeah he was
really cute they were just as Justin and
Haley as I saw those pictures yeah and
oh they were cute oh and Rachel so was
there with Roger
Robert Roger Roger and she weighs six
pounds so now my six times four ounces
difference four ounces we thought your
travels do you remember to take your you
Cora um obviously not because I'd never
remember to take anything but it
actually was delivered to my house while
I was gone so that's go for the rest of
you have shares because because I live
in constant fear of getting a UTI
because you're just traveling sitting in
dirty jeans on the dirty jeans tour by
the way nobody talks about the effects
dirty jeans has on your ability to get a
UTI I mean here we are talking about it
no we talked about me talking about you
corner before and it's truly changed our
lives because like I don't know if it's
like an us thing or like a world thing
but like I live in constant fear okay
because I've got poor hygiene like I
might get a UTI and like the travel and
we're going bathing suits so like oh you
Korra's like a it's like a pink powder
that you put in your water and makes it
taste like lemonade and it's just
preventative it's not like it just it's
not medicine it just prevents it where
it's like I feel like once you get a UTI
you are such like you have to go get
prescription medication and there really
isn't any drink orange juice cranberry
juice like does but it's not enough in
like you Cora is designed to prevent
UTIs and tastes good and I feel like not
enough people know about it and it's
great because it gets me to drink water
and I never do right so whenever you're
in a situation where you're like oh my
gosh I'm running on in the bathing suit
or like I'm gonna be the Olivia's that
try party next weekend and like after
that and then you're behind your
bachelor party like I will 100% be
getting a UTI unless I drink your or
it's you chorus season out here it's you
Cora season how do people get it get you
Cora and say goodbye to UTIs right now
you Cora is offering 30 percent off when
you text toast two four eight four eight
four eight but hurry this is a limited
time offer text toast two four eight
four eight four eight to get thirty
percent off your order of you Cora
that's toas t like that two four eight
four eight four eight really easy to
remember yeah I've actually like nothing
it's not simple no where's just a couple
of simple gals so that was my
my Hollywood Halloween and someone
offered me a ticket like to the World
Series the next time like it's so funny
cuz I was telling been like this year I
went to the Super Bowl the World Series
and the NBA all-star game I'm like I
couldn't have cared less about I I'm
crazy Emilie Ben wants to kill me
because Ben is like the ultimate sports
fan like I keep getting these
opportunities just like someone like
shits on me and like gives it and it's
like so who'd you go to the World Series
um mmm my friend Kane's friend Beecher
he had next check it was so nice to him
to give it to me I'm gonna meet a great
time they were awesome seats I saw Mark
Cuban and who else did I say Joe Jonas
again did you say hi to Mark Cuban Tim
you don't tell him did you give him in
the elevator pitch you know what's crazy
about the elevator pitch is that over my
Bachelorette weekend did I tell you this
I was in the know you did tell me and we
never spoke about I was in the elevator
I realized with Daymond John from shark
tank but I was with Rebecca we had just
gotten back from night swimming and so
we were like soaking wet and just like
having a blast and we got in the
elevator and there's a man in the
elevator but he was wearing a hat and he
was like you guys go swimming and we're
like yeah I've just feeling like
adventurous and sex is so good in those
situations even though we didn't know it
was him he was like do they have a
lifeguard out there at this time and
we're like no okay and and then he got
off on his floor and I was like that I
said to her Becca like cuz I just looked
up I was like that guy's looks I came
and John and she was like that was named
John I can't let me miss I was in an
elevator with Daymond John and I didn't
give him the elevator pitch but he
wouldn't have able to fallen on deaf
ears because I didn't look like a
consummate professional right and I was
like and it's soaking my eyes this women
like why are you soaking wet
skinny-dipping on the weekends in the
Bahamas right right okay that's so much
better it's better this way it is but I
literally was in an elevator for a pitch
that you didn't get right it's a great
I appreciate the moment you know the
fact that I could have given an elevator
and then if I was in an elevator yeah
the super bowl was fine the team that I
was rooting for laws to like that's what
I get because they were playing against
Boston we're the number one podcast boss
and that's why I get for going against
my people totally it was my fault I take
responsibility for the whole thing but
there was such good food at the ballpark
and and there was a toaster sitting next
to me oh my god there was the coolest
toaster city ask me I was watching her
and I was talking to someone and I was
like we've the coolest hands we have the
coolest fans I was at this Andrea
Bocelli concert on Thursday night and
like there was so many like a few
toasters in the room and they were just
like the best people there mhm
we have the coolest fans first of all I
noticed the girl
before she noticed me because her ring
was blinding me was the shiniest thing
biggest thing ever and she was sitting
next like this hot dude and I was like
good for this girl like her husband's
hot boyfriend whatever and then she came
over mother ta oh and I noticed her too
cuz she was wearing heels I'm like wow I
appreciate the dedication like she
obviously doesn't to be here but like
she's right now and she came over and
was like oh my god this cool girl that I
was appreciating knows me she was just
cool she'll love it
thanks missus for being cool and
representing as well and that this
wedding that I went to there were so
many toasters it was really toaster
season and I like they weren't the
cutest girls and they're having the best
time and they were just like I was so
proud you should be like a toast mother
and the toasters like they know to turn
up they're not like the girl the wedding
is like sitting on them no they were
like barefoot twerking on each other
knowing the words like every song and I
was like that is the essence of a
toaster it truly is and then obviously
the moment that everyone's been waiting
for is like something I like have a bit
about because okay so I the reason I
hope I went to LA for the first place is
like I had a bunch of meetings but I was
invited to the Gift of Life annual gala
that I had wanted to go to and then they
were honoring Kim for her work with Gift
of Life so like obviously I was gonna go
and I they promised me and the Oh bye
they obviously like the girl who like I
was working with was a toaster and she
was like don't I know how important it
is like we will get you the photo but
Kim was like late whatever they see did
me at the table right next to Kim and I
was sitting direct like literally right
next to her I was taking pictures of her
the whole time she's tiny like she must
weigh a hundred five pounds but she
doesn't look like unhealthy skinny she's
just so it's heat like she's sure these
are height yep she's so crazy oh my god
she's so tiny and that ass is firm and
it's not as big as you would think likes
weird cuz when we go to like events we
feel like the kids they're like we're
running around but she's art like she
should feel like a kid that she's such a
woman her hair looked so beautiful and
shiny like she really looked like
Aladdin cuz it was like yes she looked
at as man so oh yeah I love his boys yes
she was like jasmine she looked amazing
and just like the simple white dress and
basically the reason why she was honored
was because last year this like whole
campaign went viral looking for a bone
marrow match for this guy named Adam who
was like a dad of three like he had just
had a six month old kid and hit him and
his wife like started this whole
campaign and they got so big and their
kids go to the same school as one of
Kim's friends daughters and they told
Kim about it and Kim was like so like
involved she had tweeted about it but
what the the the wife of the guy who
needed the match gave her the award she
was like nobody knows like him calls me
all the time like comes to my house make
sure my kids are okay like she really
takes care of my sign the match well so
they found a partial so he the reason
why it so hard to find a match is
because it's ethnically targeted so like
if we needed a match god forbid a
million times I would you would need
that someone Ashkenazi Jewish Eastern
European like it's based on your
background which is why I like the more
ethnic you are like you should really
join the registry so he was like
Moroccan French she was like ELISA I
found out about this whole thing from my
friend Lisa who's Moroccan French and
she held to drive like for all of her
Moroccan cousins like there there's so
few people who have the same background
as him so they found someone who's like
a partial match which is an ideal and it
didn't work and he ended up passing away
like a couple months after they found
the match um and his wife was there and
she was like so beautiful I'm like she
was like talking about him and like I
couldn't stop crying it was the saddest
thing ever like it was the most amazing
night like she was so like happy to be
there and so the way that it works by
the way everyone should join the
registry if you like not enough people
know about it like it's not giving blood
like it's a cheek swab it's noisy and
people think because like if you're gay
you can't give blood the bone marrow
registry is very LGBTQ friendly everyone
can get their cheek swab and if
regardless of once you if you are
matched they have to put you through a
physical which you have to pass which I
feel like I literally wouldn't it's just
like general health will say people you
gotta treadmill you know like in her
neck yes and so if you're a match I mean
these people like literally wait years
to be a match and if you're not you not
allowed to meet the person that you give
your bone marrow to for a year just in
case like doesn't work out like they
don't want you to get attached so there
that night they had two people reunite
for the first time ever number unite you
know but the for the first time ever the
people that gave them their matches and
it was the cutest thing ever like I
literally cuz i prying one was his four
year old girl who got a match and he was
just like oh my god it was so great it
made me like really like a reinvigorated
to support gift of life which we are
doing for our toast cycle we're doing fo
my biggest re right at soul cycle
November 8th tickets are bikes are sold
out you can still donate you'll donate
which everyone should because I think
you should all work towards a goal all
proceeds are being donated to the gift
of life bone our registration yeah
registry
regardless so Kim got her word she like
gave such
shoot speed she was like took a picture
and she left and I was like oh my god
they did not arrange my photo like I
know that there was more important
things going on like the gala but I was
like annoyed and they like are you near
me I ran out to go find her and I ran
into her on her way out and like it was
so not ideal I was an animal
I bet she wanted to say no but she would
never say no like she would have her
bodyguard be like get out of the way but
no one was paying attention and I like
shoved in my phone and someone I was
like take it like I was being crazy
because I had been in my mind whenever I
see a celebrity that I want to take a
picture with I chickened out and Ben
always yells and he's like that was your
opportunity that was opportunity so I
had been in my brain I'm like this is my
opportunity and you couldn't come back
with my picture Jackie I was insane I
looked terrible
I couldn't even afterwards it was just
terrible like I had all these things I
want to say to her like I want to be
like I'm the girl who sat on the kimochi
chocolate heart and broke up with her
ass if you retweeted it I want to be
like we have mutual friends Simon said I
could drop his name and I'm like
honestly for your sake just be glad I
did it I didn't drop your name Simon
because I was out of control you could
pretend like you don't know me like I
was an animal but I got the picture
that's all I'm a nerd and I'm never ski
and the picture is so cute it's whatever
it's whatever like was it ideal no but
you got the picture it was good it
wasn't great that I entered I'd been
there so many times like and I had a pit
about it like the whole flight home
it's okay cuz I'm like no I'm always
gonna be the girl that like attacked her
no it's okay she has so many people
attack her she doesn't remember well you
know what that's what it was so she was
sitting like a regular person at the
gala while everything was going on like
people were harassing her like have some
social decency like there's someone
speaking like shut up she couldn't sit
there anymore like they had to move her
and bring her back out for her award but
like she tried and I was like damn like
that's annoying like yeah he literally
walked she opened the door from
backstage and had probably a 50 foot
walked to her car and like I attacked
her and a paparazzi attacked her which I
got the background of that's annoying
yeah like but that but then she also has
a house full of flower arrangements and
when she left the gala her bodyguard was
holding the biggest box from Aries so
you know what everything has a price
ever even if even if it's a there's no
such thing as a free armies gift
no no there's no such thing as a free
photo I sacrificed my dignity for it
thank you we respect your service here
we go being like what should I ever say
in the video write it so it always goes
actors the best laid plans anyways I'm
so beat I'm glad my wig is snatch snatch
you guys yeah let's see one can we come
on yeah we doing and now we have dr.
Phil thanks so much for being here
sorry we've been ma we're back every day
this week TJ and we're here for the
first half of next week but they may be
Libby's bachelorette party yeah oh we
have premium guest next week too oh yeah
we have a podcast with Melissa Borge or
go with Margaret Josie's New Jersey week
next week and then we also have Teresa
but I won't be here for that so we need
a premium ask oh [ __ ] we did I'm gonna
be in Charlotte I edit a second show in
Charlotte and there's a few tickets left
I'm also gonna be in Birmingham Alabama
and then finishing the gear off in Miami
by the way are you guys gonna come to
Miami sure cuz I was thinking of like
throwing it afterparty
oh you know what that actually works for
me because then I'm going on vacation
but it's halfway oh great my baking
steps thinking like it's a Thursday
night 7:30 show just one show and then
it's my last row 20:18 like we should
throw a party yeah and it's gonna make
plans but I want to make sure like
people would be there okay I have to
rearrange some flights but you can count
me in I don't have much of a choice I'll
make it work everything you all for
tuning in happy Halloween have the other
one Jordan to spoon
[Music]
you